[inaudible]
do you want to meet today is an evolutionary psychologist and author and
associate professor at the University of New Mexico.
Jeffrey Miller.
Welcome to the Rubin report to Dave.
Great to be here.
Good to be with you.
My friend.
You know,
I realized I've had evolutionary biologists on the show.
I've had Bret Weinstein and Richard Dawkins.
I've had psychologists on the show,
Jordan Peterson.
I've never had an evolutionary psychologist.
Never know for many of us how many of how many are there were almost extinct.
Um,
the big international conference we get maybe 300 people versus like a big
neuroscience conference will be 30,000.
That's gotta be a tough crowd.
It's a tough crowd.
Um,
we get a lot of flack from all directions,
but I would,
I wouldn't want to do anything else.
It's an that's an awesome field.
And um,
I can't imagine anything more fun than studying human nature for a living.
Yeah.
And you're studying and I've written about so many incredible topics.
I normally,
I always am PR.
I pride myself on the fact that I usually don't have to look at my notes when
interviewing somebody.
But you've hit so many things that every now and again I am going to be glancing
down cause I don't want to miss anything here.
But usually the way I like to start these is just finding out a little bit of
someone's history,
what sort of brought them to the place of expertise that gets them in that
chair.
So just tell me a little bit about,
uh,
you know,
growing up education,
that sort of thing.
What made you interested in all this?
Oh,
I was born and raised in Cincinnati,
Ohio.
Went to Undergrad at Columbia University.
I studied psychology and biology and just anything that grabbed my interest.
So I kind of started out in neuroscience and I thought the brain's fascinating.
And then I kind of drifted into cognitive psychology,
which is studying human learning and memory and perception and how we categorize
stuff.
And then I got really bored with that,
but I thought,
I dunno,
I'll go,
I'll go ph,
do a phd in that.
Anyway,
so I went to Stanford,
started doing cognitive psychology,
but when I was there,
I met these two brilliant,
um,
postdocs who were working with my advisor lead a cosmetic cosmetics and John
[inaudible] who had just come from Harvard and they basically invented the field
of evolutionary psychology right there at Stanford in front of my nose.
Hmm.
From the ground up.
And they were like,
we're going to take evolutionary biology,
anthropology,
cognitive psychology,
merge them all together and make this new science of human nature.
So let's slow down for a second.
What does that say that this is look like?
What does that even mean when they're talking about this?
How do you take these things that are thought of as their own institutions and
you know,
put them into one box?
It's basically like the,
the key insight is if you want to understand human nature,
whether it's anything human sexuality or emotions or how we relate to other
people or other groups,
you can always ask the,
where did we come from,
what challenges that our ancestors face in terms of surviving and reproducing
and raising kids?
And what exact structure did those challenges have?
Like what was ancestral life like?
We don't know every,
every detail,
but we do know a lot from anthropologists who had studied hunter gatherers.
We know a lot from primatologists who have studied,
um,
chimps and Bonobos and gorillas and orangutans.
And you can kind of triangulate on a picture of prehistoric life and figure out,
yeah.
Like why do we fear certain things,
snakes and spiders and bears and whatever.
Well,
it's because there were certain selection pressures.
Like if you don't fear those things,
you die.
Why do we look for certain things in mates when we're choosing sexual partners?
Well,
if you don't look for those things,
then you have bad relationships and bad kids,
etc. So it's a,
a way of looking at the past to inform our understanding of the present.
Um,
and that's not what most of psychology does.
So it's quite a novel kind of approach.
But I think we've got,
we've gotten enormous leverage out of it.
Was there pushback from people within each discipline going,
Whoa,
we've got all the answers right here.
Why do we want to put these things together?
Cause I would imagine there's always a certain inherent competition amongst all
of these different disciplines.
Yeah.
The evolution biologists kind of hate it.
Yeah,
because that was going to be my next question since I know there's a couple of
those guys,
they're
happy to go,
here's how other animals evolve.
They're happy to go,
here's how the human body evolved.
Here's how the human immune system involved.
But once you got above the neck,
then they're like,
you're just going to make trouble for us in biology because that's where things
got politically controversial is when you start explaining human behavior or
individual differences are sex differences or human emotions with stuff like
that.
So the biologists don't like it.
The anthropologists had a lot of the same issues.
Like we've spent the last century trying to get anthropology kind of away from
biology in a way.
So please don't drag us kicking and screaming back into that,
that swamp of controversy.
Um,
but we just kind of plowed ahead.
And,
um,
and I think it's been a big success story in the sciences in the last 30 years.
So what were the things that were intriguing to you that had sort of board you
for that?
I think that the fact that sexuality is central to evolutionary biology and
evolutionary psychology,
you know,
it's how,
how we get our genes and the next generation is choosing mates and having babies
and raising,
raising kids.
And if you ignore that you ignore,
I think one of the core driving forces in human nature and human culture.
Now,
most of psychology kind of ignores a mate choice and sexuality and reproduction,
um,
except insofar as it's kind of like seen as politically relevant.
So like you'll get a little bit on while their sexual discrimination against
certain kind of groups,
which is important to address like gay and lesbian rights and,
and so forth.
Um,
but they don't really see it as central to who we are into what motivates us.
So do you see it as,
as the real pillar of what's motivating us?
Like if we were sort of looking at this in concentric circles,
I think
it depends on where you're at in life.
I think for young single people,
what we call mating effort,
like the attempt to attract other people,
whatever your sexual orientation,
that drives an awful lot of behavior,
how you dress,
what I ideas you adopt,
um,
why you bother to learn things,
why you bother to get credentials.
I think a lot of that is driven by meeting effort,
but then if you settle down and you're in a long term monogamous relationship,
you don't kind of need to do that stuff.
But that's exactly when people get lazy.
That's where people let themselves go.
Right?
Um,
they don't say in shape,
they dress more sloppily.
They kind of don't bother reading like serious nonfiction anymore.
Um,
why?
Because a lot of that sort of creative display has already accomplished.
It's its purpose.
So in that way,
that's not in real conflict with evolutionary biology,
right?
Because you want to look your best to get the best mate and all that.
So in that way,
you guys are on the same practice.
So where does that,
where does that DV,
well,
so when biologists talk about courtship displays and here's the bower bird
building its power and we talk about like ideological displays and here's people
showing off their virtues through virtue signaling,
the biologists know exactly what we're talking about and we know exactly what
they're talking about.
It's just often they don't want to get into trouble that that follows if they
kind of make these analogies.
GS
Two clearly.
Have you had any of these conversations with Bret Weinstein?
Not Directly.
No.
I think I'm going to have to facilitate that one probably.
That'd be a lot of fun.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we'll do that for sure.
So it's interesting.
Okay,
so let's,
let's focus on the sexuality parties for a little bit because it seems like so
many things that we used to be able to talk about we suddenly can't talk about
or that academics are self selecting out of and things of that nature.
Now,
I said to you right before we started,
you're one of the few people I see on Twitter and I'm like,
oh he kind of gets what Twitter is cause you put out some smart stuff.
You're kind of funny on there at the right time,
you know when to go with snark and all of those things and that to seems the
only way
that you would be able to have any of these conversations online.
I think social media is actually really good for addressing some of these very
tricky issues like human sexuality and how it's playing out in the modern world
as long as you do it with humor and self deprecation and a little bit of
absurdity,
which is what I try to do in my Twitter game,
right?
Because if you approach it like well here's the next paper on like sex
differences or the next paper on how courtship works or oh awesome.
A new virtue signaling paper.
People will quickly tune out on the last off often think,
well,
you're just kind of being doctrinaire here.
But the thing you quickly realize if you study evolution at all,
his evolution is a very weird process that often produces completely absurd
results,
right?
You Watch any David Attenborough natural history,
you know,
documentary and it's like these animals are insane.
What they're doing is crazy and humans are no different.
And if you don't have a sense of that absurdity,
then it's very easy to get terribly,
terribly serious and censorious and ideological and that really kept the highs.
A lot doesn't,
it's going on.
That doesn't really help anybody.
All right,
so let's,
let's pause on sexuality for a second.
I don't want to get off that topic so to speak,
but um,
let's just do the two minute,
uh,
Twitter portion of the show,
which is,
is there a evolutionary explanation to the way we're behaving with each other?
Is there a psychological explanation to the way we act one way on this medium
and another way on another medium and,
and how that has evolved because of communication?
It's a great question.
And I think honestly,
social media blindsided everybody.
I don't know anybody in the 90s in psychology or any behavioral science who's
going,
here's what the Internet is going to turn into,
right?
It'll become this massive global system of very rapid fire,
interactive,
snarky virtue signaling that drives everyone nuts.
And yet we can't give it up.
Yeah,
I know Villain k Dick probably wouldn't,
but maybe nobody else.
Yeah.
Okay.
Dick,
maybe William Gibson,
a few other folks kind of add the insight.
But honestly,
nobody was derived and kind of from first principles.
Well,
we are a social primate and we love to gossip and we love to show off our,
you know,
our,
our virtues and our intelligence to each other.
And therefore,
obviously there'll be this thing called Facebook and Twitter and whatever,
and it will
play out in this way and moreover it will revolutionize politics or culture in
some way.
No,
nobody thought that.
So we can come up with post-talk reasons why that might've played out that way.
Um,
but I went on,
only do that with a very high degree of humility.
Like,
I don't know,
I don't,
now that we're here,
you can kind of a little bit make sense of it that well.
So almost like you can see the evolution,
Twitter,
you know what I mean?
Where you now see people,
I'd like to include myself in that,
where they're trying to clean it up a little bit.
It's like we all did this unknown thing of snark and everyone was trying to
destroy each other and one up each other in virtue signal about the things we
care about and all that.
And it's like now I'm seeing a growing group of people that are like,
Whoa,
how do we deal with reality in the confines of social media?
But when the cerulean honestly and without just wrecking everything and that
almost strikes me as a evolutionary function and its evolution is happening so
fast and on such a huge scale.
I mean who could have predicted that?
Like the more amateurish looking a visual meme is,
the better it would spread.
That's completely bizarre.
Um,
or the fact that I can get more engagement if I do a really surreal poll on
Twitter about something where all four categories are just completely insane.
Like people are more into that.
Right.
Then they are like even my snarky comment about political issue x or y.
So what does that tell you about the psychological state of how we interact with
these things?
Like the main ones really interesting.
It's not the sleigh he produced thing,
you know,
really sharp looking images that go viral.
It's,
you know,
a frog on up black and white idiotic thing or crudely drawn yes.
Or that tree or whatever.
Like there's something really there today about how we react to images to this.
Also something kind of charming about the artlessness and amateurish quality.
It's almost like I'm kind of fascinated by stand up comedy on the standup
Comedians who are overly slick or never that funny.
And the ones who are a little bit shambolic like Steven right back in the 80s,
hilarious.
And he looks,
he looks like he's always on the edge of complete failure or a psychotic break.
And yet that's what makes it work.
Or I guess Seinfeld,
you know,
in the 90s,
um,
to show it was also kind of has this artless quality.
Yeah.
Alright,
so let's jump back.
So that Saturday now it's getting harder and harder to talk about these things.
There's a set of people that think we're all exactly the same and then at the
same time they're obsessed with all of our differences.
I mean this is what seemingly is the most potent idea of the day right now.
Um,
what are,
what are the things that you're thinking about in realm of sexuality
right now that are intrigued?
I'm thinking,
I'm especially concerned about the fact that nobody seems to know what a
successful long term relationship is seriously gonna look like in the early to
mid 21st century that we don't really have a script for that we've kind of
inherited,
you know,
the script of monogamous lifelong marriage,
but nobody really believes that that is going to kind of solve all of our
problems and people don't enter enter into that very early in life.
They spend their teens and twenties doing casual dating.
What is that like?
Nobody quite understands what the rules are,
the ethics of that are,
and that at a certain point you kind of get tired of that and you find a partner
and you kind of settled down and go,
okay,
we're going to buy into the wedding industry now and do the wedding thing and
the ring and bottle.
But they're all these subcultures in America and around the world that are
exploring all different aspect sexuality and kind of how to incorporate new
insights into relationships.
Things like,
um,
BDSM or kink or polyamory and open relationships or the whole red pill
manosphere subculture.
Um,
and then on the other side of the plug that have to do with sexuality,
well,
it's a certain way of,
of men and women interacting,
right?
This sort of red pill vision of Male,
female dynamics is that there's a really deep sexual polarity,
masculine and feminine.
And if you don't understand that polarity,
your relationships,
if they're heterosexual,
are going to fail and burnout and not be satisfying to either person.
So there's much subcultures.
They're all,
uh,
exploring different parts of human nature,
human sexuality,
different possible ways to run a relationship.
And I think they all have valuable lessons that we can kind of learn and
incorporate.
Like even if your vanilla and monogamous and straight and you,
you don't believe all the,
the crazy manosphere stuff,
there's still important lessons there.
And that's kind of my interest now is sort of going around and,
and being eclectic and gathering those up and figuring out what,
which of those might be useful.
Do people
stay in those scenes for,
for a lifetime.
So I,
you know,
I could see where s where somebody,
you'd be an a whatever your thing is and I'm not passing judgment on Ebay.
Whatever your thing is,
you do it for awhile and then eventually I guess it sort of is the,
you sort of get tired of it so you move on to something more traditional.
Like is that just part of our psychology?
Like nothing kind of lasts forever.
Some people do that.
Certainly there's a,
there's a life profile kind of openness and experimentation where you try a
bunch of stuff in your teens and 20s on a lot of it deviates markedly from the
traditional culture you,
you grow up in and a lot of that um,
hurts and it doesn't work and it's heartbreaking.
And then a lot of people kind of drift back into the mainstream.
On the other hand,
you got people who marry young and they try the,
the standard vanilla monogamy thing into their thirties,
forties,
50s and then go,
this is not working.
I need something different,
better,
more open,
whatever.
And I think,
um,
it can go either way.
You know,
the psychological research on all these subcultures is lacking.
We don't know even which lasts longer.
A monogamous relationship or an open relationship.
Everybody,
we don't know.
There's not good data on that.
Huh?
There's lots of anecdotes.
There's examples on both sides,
but I think it's
almost scientific misconduct not to ask those questions and instead to ask like,
let's do,
you know,
study on which alcoholism treatment works.
Let's do the 5000th study on that before we do the first study on what kind of
relationships last longest.
So basically because you think if we could address some of those issues first,
perhaps the studies that we're focusing on unrelated out there as well as him
and the rest.
Yeah,
relationship satisfaction is really,
really important to people.
Um,
but it's one of the things that's,
it's not entirely taboo to study it,
but it's pretty hard to get federal research funding to look at something that's
kind of a cornerstone of American wellbeing.
So when that New York Times article came out about Jordan Peterson and they said
he was four in forced monogamy,
which in effect just means marriage.
And have you used a couple of times in the times before?
Just to me marriage.
But everyone thought that man,
he wanted me in chains to be,
you know,
dragged around by their husbands.
The,
the argument that people that are for enforcement,
I,
we are married basically make is that this is the best way to build a sort of
functioning healthy society and that you can reproduce and have other
generations.
And all of those things.
You just think we don't have enough information basically or enough.
Um,
right.
Well enough study on the information to know if that really is the best way to
build a
humane society.
Right.
We don't know if there's,
there's good reasons to think that um,
monogamous marriage has been important in every major civilization.
Like it's kind of the most common way to arrange pair bonding.
Um,
and I'm sure Jordan Peterson has read the same articles I've assigned even in my
polyamory class.
That's about here are the benefits of monogamous marriage and there are many of
it.
The question is once you have contraception,
once you have safer sex and STI testing,
once you have paternity testing,
once you have a lot of other technologies,
right,
the can solve some of the same issues that monogamy used to solve,
then what is monogamy still optimal?
Probably is for a lot of people probably is for lot.
How much of it do you think just comes down to how you're wired?
I think there's a lot of that.
Some people are just wired to go,
man,
I just want a pair bond.
I want my mate and I want to keep it simple and that's good enough for me and I
will get a lot of companion at love and attachment and it'll last a long time.
A lot of people are very happy with that and that's great.
But a lot of people either want more sexual novelty and variety or they have a
higher tolerance for sexual jealousy,
um,
or they just kind of get bored and longterm relationships.
And I think those people should not be prescribing like rampant polyamory for
the monogamists,
but the monogamous shouldn't necessarily be prescribing like our way is the only
way for everybody else.
So I wonder how this is all related to the gay community because I don't know,
dare I mentioned the name Milo,
but when I had my low on my show years ago,
really before he was in Milan,
so to speak,
um,
we got it.
We had about a half hour chat on this where me as the married gay liberal and
him as the unmarried gay conservative,
which is already sort of a flip on things.
His argument was that he wasn't really for gay marriage because he felt that by
being the outsider,
the gays have come up with art and creativity and music and comedy and all of
that incredible,
like just gestalt of it all that made this incredible community,
like a diverse community in the right sense of diversity.
Yeah.
And my argument was,
well,
you've got to at least give people the opportunity to be equal under the law so
that they at least have a choice.
I'm not denying that the gay community has come up with all sorts of incredible
stuff.
Yeah.
But like you gotta make them equal and then let them go either way on that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you think there is legitimacy to that and do you,
have you done or have you seen any studies on what the effects of the,
of marriage on the gay community have been?
I haven't seen a whole lot,
but I guess Molly too soon.
I mean,
my understanding,
some of this comes from Dan Dan's habits,
right?
Is that a lot of gay couples have a kind of monogamish relationship where it's
like,
we are pair bonded,
we love each other,
but there's also a negotiated agreement that we can have outside lovers once in
a while under certain conditions that we kind of mutually agree to see.
It's funny,
I hear
that all the time and I don't know,
advocate couples that I know that are,
that are married or,
you know,
really yeah.
Together.
I don't know ones that are like that or at least that I know that they are like
that.
Let's put it that way.
Okay.
But I know that this is,
uh,
something that's tossed out there so we can go with this for
so,
but I'm sure there's variety and I'm sure that there's also kind of social
assortment.
All right.
So that the more monogamous gay,
lesbian couples will kind of be more comfortable with each other and they might
know those crazy monogamish folks down the road,
but,
um,
or you just don't know your friends that well.
I mean,
I guess anything's possible.
Yeah.
And honestly,
it's not that different from like the way,
um,
even heterosexual relationships work in a lot of Europe where a lot of those are
tacitly monogamish and there's a sort of understanding that um,
monogamy doesn't necessarily mean sexual exclusivity for either partner.
Um,
America is extremely puritanical and kind of rigid about that and we think,
um,
anything that happens outside the pair bond is almost by definition unethical.
Um,
and there is research on sort of anti polyamory stigma where people actually are
more prejudiced against people in open relationships then they are against
almost any other group.
Um,
in terms of orientation or race or religion or,
or anything.
Um,
that might be gradually changing,
but I think it's a,
it's a huge social problem,
especially among Gen z and younger millennials.
Yeah.
Where does the trans part of this all fit in?
Because I remember years ago when people would say,
when I,
when everyone started saying the LGBT community,
I remember thinking,
I have no more insight into the t part of this,
then a straight cisgendered heterosexual male.
Would,
you know what I mean?
I,
I just,
I don't,
I may be,
I have somehow slightly a little more inherent empathy by being an outsider at
some level,
but I don't have any more knowledge of it.
And now it seems like the Trans issue has almost superseded all of the other
issues at least in the last year.
I mean everywhere.
Yeah.
Everywhere you go there's,
you know,
every time I opened the Twitter search bar,
it's another trans story or someone's being fired for this joke or that or the
other.
What do you think happened there that catapulted this so quickly and what are
the issues around it that were kind of afraid to talk about right now?
It's a really complicated fraught topic I think trying to get you,
I think it's like,
I'm an issue about trans is there are people who um,
are trans or field trends and they want their rights respected and that's
totally legitimate and good for them.
And raising awareness about that is fine.
There's a larger group of people who I think are using trans issues as a kind of
wedge to destroy the gender binary or to kind of muddy the waters or basically
as a weapon to beat up evolutionary psychology or evolutionary biology to say
there's no such thing as sex.
Really.
There's no such thing as biological sex or sex is totally dissociated from
gender,
et Cetera.
When someone says that the next time someone says that on Twitter,
what's the answer that the person watching this should give?
That maybe Twitter is not the best one report,
I mean male and female or evolved strategies that exist because over thousands
of generations they were like the paths to successful reproduction.
Um,
if you're not clearly male and functioning as a male or you're not clearly
female and functioning as a female,
you're your genetic dead end.
So selection hammers against any ambiguity there.
So it's not surprising that the vast majority of humans alive today clearly
identify as one sex or the other.
Um,
that doesn't mean everyone should,
it doesn't have any kind of moral implications about that.
But just descriptively,
it means there is a gender binary ended,
evolved for good reasons and everyone teaches biology hopefully knows this and
it shouldn't be that controversial right now.
If we want to like genetically engineer people and use CRISPR and whatever to
destroy the gender binary for the 22nd and 23rd centuries,
we could do that.
We could talk about that.
Um,
I don't have any particular attachment to the kind of male,
female dichotomy ethically.
Um,
but I think descriptively it's really important to kind of accept it and to go,
if it's here,
it's valuable to understand and we shouldn't necessarily try to pretend it out
of existence,
um,
or pretend that we're doing it in the name of Trans Rights.
Right?
You can have trans rights without saying there's no such thing as sex.
So this gets to the heart of what I think is really happening in this country
right now,
which is everything has become politicized to the point that the experts in the
field seem afraid to talk to you right now are taking a risk by talking about
these issues.
Yeah.
Are you seeing this across the board?
You,
are you seeing this amongst colleagues of fear to talk about these things?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Now the vast majority of people like at my university don't really touch upon
anything that's particularly politicized,
right?
They're just teaching civil engineering or law or,
um,
immunology or whatever.
And most of that isn't really politicized yet,
however yet is the key word that,
right,
right.
Okay.
I mean,
you get a little bit bit about what's the gender representation in certain
fields,
but
in my department,
in psychology,
you do get almost everything having a kind of political edge.
And I have colleagues who are frightened to teach certain classes.
Like I teach psychology of human sexuality and I'm pretty upfront and outspoken
about what I cover and what my view is.
But a lot of my colleagues will not touch it with a barge pole because there's
so much risk that students will just get upset about one little thing you say.
Yeah.
And complained to a dean and then you'll get called into the office.
And,
um,
so what would be that type of thing but beyond what you just said about the
yeah.
And the evidence of,
of gender differences,
what,
what are the other types of things that just talking about are scaring the
academics?
It's very awkward to talk about sex differences in any mental traits or
motivations or preferences.
It's hard to talk about sexual coercion,
rape date,
rape,
harassment,
stalking,
etc. That was being incredibly difficult one.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
it's hard to talk about,
um,
aggression in general,
either between individuals or between groups and how that relates to sexuality.
Like why hunter gatherer tribes go to war,
right?
It's not typically about land or food,
it's about women and that doesn't fit the kind of Marxist picture of prehistoric
warfare.
Right.
And then if you talked about stuff like,
um,
pregnancy,
child care,
parenting,
are you being,
you know,
overly pro natalist and sort of family values for talking about that stuff?
Is that alienating to certain students who might be homosexual or infertile or,
or adopted kids or whatever?
Um,
it's so interesting because I obviously hear these types of stories from
academics all the time,
not only in here but,
but online.
And people email me all the time.
It's like,
God,
we've failed.
I mean,
the university really had failed at that point.
Like if you're afraid to talk about child rearing because that might upset a gay
person.
Yeah.
Jesus.
I mean,
what's left at that point?
It's so frustrating and it means I feel bad for the students,
but I also feel bad for the parents who are often footing the tuition bill
because the parents have faith that if I send my kid to a state university and I
paid tens of thousands and tuition and they take a course on topic x,
like human sexuality,
that they're going to get professors who are willing to profess to say what they
really think and often are not getting that.
So there's a kind of bait and switch where universities are pretending to be
these bastions of free speech and inquiry and,
and honesty.
And in fact,
um,
everyone's kind of running scared and these kids are not getting our best
insights.
They're paying the money,
but we're not delivering the service.
How much of an infection,
not just in the classroom.
Do you see this as,
but I think,
correct me if I'm wrong,
I think you've written around 110 published papers.
Is that right?
Did I get the exact number right?
Is it a hundred more or less?
More or less?
You lose count anything at some point.
I'm sure you're well aware of the Peter [inaudible] socal hoax,
that it's not just what's happening in the classroom that's causing the chaos,
but it actually may be what's happening before that related to all of these
papers that certain disciplines basically have.
I don't think I'm all the rest of waiting.
They almost have no standards.
Yeah.
At this point that that is got to be just incredibly frustrating for someone
that actually has published some things legitimately.
It's kind of frustrating,
but I can see you don't get frustrated easily.
But I'm like,
it doesn't bug me as much as maybe it bugged some other people.
Partly because
I spent a lot of my undergraduate,
um,
years taking courses on
critical theory and I read a lot of dairy,
Don Fuko and Leotard and all those French dudes.
And one reason I loved those courses is it was so easy to get an a by writing a
kind of bullshit paper using the right terms and using sufficiently obscure
syntax.
Right.
That so I know that game.
God,
that's real.
Very well.
It's really real and it's great fun.
I understand the appeal
of that stuff.
It's just,
I can't imagine spending my adult life doing nothing but that and that's what's
happening in a lot of the humanities.
So it like if,
if those folks want to do that and get paid,
typically not a very good salary to do that.
I don't,
it doesn't really,
this really offend me.
The only dangerous when is when they turn into activists and they give people
like me grief based on not understanding what I do.
Well,
I would imagine a lot of interest in leaks into your classroom and then,
and all bets are off.
It's weird.
It doesn't actually leak in.
Like when I teach human sexuality,
right.
The kids have a sort of vague,
um,
political correctness that they've absorbed mostly in k 12 public school
I think.
But if you actually ask them,
have you had any courses on gender feminism?
No.
Have you heard of any of these leading figures from critical theory or history
of feminism or even history of gay rights?
I know nothing about,
so it's not like they've been indoctrinated,
at least not in big state schools,
but they've kind of soaked up some stuff from high school.
I think that influences how they interpret everything.
So as you guys wearing,
might I say very nice shirts right now is shiny purple shirt and a shiny blue
shirt.
Let's talk about evolutionary aesthetics.
Told people don't talk about aesthetics.
Yeah,
that much.
But you think that sort of the things we're looking at in the west or maybe not
as exciting as they should be and that there's a problem there,
is that
fair to say?
Yeah,
I've been really into art for a long time and I think art and beauty are
important,
um,
particularly to places people live and work.
And I think as humans we kind of deserve the best from artists,
interior designers,
um,
stylists,
whatever architects that make our lives as pleasant as possible.
And I think basically ever since about 1910,
art in architecture is failed as not done.
A very good job of delivering visual environments that are actually humane and
appealing and enjoyable and that kind of promote mental and physical health.
What happened around 19 modernism,
man,
um,
if you look at the way domestic architecture worked up until about that period,
it was all sort of human scale and arts and crafts and um,
there are places you'd want to live where you didn't have to be educated into a
particular elite notion of what a house should be in order to appreciate it,
right?
And then you get the Bauhaus,
international modernism,
white structures,
Chris part lines,
um,
bad acoustics.
And suddenly that becomes the fashion,
right?
That becomes what people think or is the future.
And nobody likes it,
but it's kind of imposed top down by the elite.
You must live like this,
like it or not.
Is that top down from the elite or is that just that often those things are just
easier to build probably and cheaper to build or maybe that's the same actually.
It's like you could have taken cheap,
easy to build reinforced concrete structures and built a lot of all,
some cheap houses that were okay or you could do the traditional route,
but instead of what you get is every house must be distinct and must have its
own shape and there can't be any,
um,
standardization.
So the houses end up being expensive and experimental and hard to maintain and
they leak and everyone's miserable.
Um,
so they're not really serving the needs of the,
the people at large,
they're just
great for architect egos.
Yeah.
It's interesting because I just spent a couple of months bouncing through a lot
of different countries in Europe,
you know,
especially while most of these countries,
because the history goes back so far,
you see incredible architecture.
You see,
you know,
I'd see chairs that were 150 years old and like the woodwork that would go into
it and the craftsmen shit.
And it was like,
I don't think we could do this today or if we could do it today,
this would've caught,
this chair would be in our dollars.
It would be like a $6,500 chair where back then,
you know,
this is what a guy did.
It took him a couple of days and he could sell it and earn a wage and it's like
we've just,
the economics of everything had gotten out of whack.
Yeah.
And like nice table here and this slash probably slide it on the table right
when you walked in.
So I know you made it.
I've made a few pieces of furniture in my day and that's,
that's pretty cool.
But yeah,
it was a visual art in particular.
Um,
the economics mean like abstract painting just is so much faster to do than
representational painting,
right?
If you're a young aspiring artist and you want a career and you want to give
your gallery a certain flow of work that they can sell,
it's a lot harder to do that.
If you're doing representational paintings that take a hundred,
300 hours than an abstract work that takes a 10th of that.
So the economic pressures are also in that direction.
Yeah.
Um,
but people have,
um,
kind of voted with their feet and like they don't like elite abstract art.
They don't like conceptual art.
Um,
like the word the right word.
They are or they just don't,
they just don't know or it's conditioning or it's that we all like to like what
everybody else likes sort of thing.
I think everybody knows that that kind of supposed to enjoy going to like while
we're visiting the city,
we should go to the contemporary art museum and they get there and there's a
bunch of terrible video art and there's a bunch of very puzzling conceptual art.
And they read the little descriptions on the walls and they go,
it,
this makes no sense cause it's written by an art curator for other art curators.
And it's all completely alienating.
And that's,
that's sad because it means they're being told this is the highest expression of
your culture,
but it's completely inaccessible to you.
So what,
uh,
what do you look at that give me some excitement or can still sort of
renew your spirit,
let's say?
Well there,
there is a movement of kind of neo traditionalism and,
and art where there's,
there's certain places like New York Academy of Arts that are actually teaching
students how to draw and paint and sculpt and,
and do the sort of traditional,
um,
skills that people associate with art.
Um,
it's just a little hard to get a foothold in the,
like the New York or London gallery system.
If that's the kind of work that you do.
Um,
but my hope is that like the bay area billionaires,
we'll start collecting that stuff.
Um,
I think the Chinese aren't market is,
has got a real thirst for good representational art and I think that's going to
start to dominate the art world pretty soon.
So what's the evolutionary need for good art?
I mean what's the psychological,
I mean I know you're okay.
There's an expression of something that can't quite be said,
but what's like the driving force behind that?
So yeah,
on the one hand there's,
why do we bother to make art?
On the other hand,
why,
why do we like certain kinds of art?
And there's been a lot more research on why did we like certain kinds of
patterns and colors and forms and compensations and whatever.
But there's no sort of unified theory of,
of aesthetics.
In fact,
I would say there's more good stuff published on that topic between about 18,
17,
19,
20 than since.
Cause that's when people were sort of there inspired by Darwin.
Evolutionary aesthetics was a field.
There were dozens of books published on it.
And then modernism came and everyone forgot all that.
How could this be connected to the earlier topic,
which is sexuality?
So for example,
my gay male friends generally speaking,
have a much better eye for art or for style or for fashion.
You know,
you could get away in that crew,
you know what I mean?
Like you've got a nice blanket on,
you got to make sure that,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I mean,
that is a compliment.
Like where Jen,
again,
just broadly speaking,
it's like my straight guy friends,
all kinds of wear big shirts and they don't know exactly how to do their hair
and their,
you know,
so there's some connection between sexuality and artistic vision.
I think that's absolutely true.
And it's not what you would predict from first principles.
It's really weird.
If you look around at other species,
the males are typically much more ornamental than the females.
They have the,
the amazing plumage and they do the incredible songs and dances and the females
are usually kind of drab and not that aesthetic.
The bower birds that make these incredible kind of installation works.
That's all the males.
Then you get to humans or at least American males,
American straight males.
And it's like,
can't you even find
clothes that fit would like colors that is the big shark and like what is up
with your house?
You know,
and when I did the Jordan Peter's until 2 million copies to tell people to clean
their room.
Yeah.
So I have no idea why gay men had better taste than straight men.
I think that's a fascinating,
there's some,
there has to be something going on there.
Um,
but I think men can level up obviously cause like British and European men
aren't as hopeless.
If you grow up a young man in Italy,
you kind of absorb some ideas about style and even the British,
um,
kind of aristocrats landed.
Gentry class have a certain look that it's a bit traditionalist,
but at least there's taste.
I don't know if he's going to quite make sense,
but we're,
we almost getting there say 10 years ago with the rise of the metro sexual.
Yeah,
man,
it's sort of crashed because I guess maybe it relates back to what you said at
the beginning about where we are more puritan.
So were there was this idea there was this like mocking of them like Ah,
they're just gay but don't want to admit it or something like that.
And that whole thing seemed to crash.
Like there was this little brief window where straight guys were like dressing
better had cooler haircuts or something,
something there.
Well,
even five years ago when I lived in New York for a little bit,
uh,
I hung out,
hung out a lot in Brooklyn.
There was sort of,
that was peak hipster in,
in Brooklyn and the guys there,
the straight guys put a lot of effort into grooming and haircuts and authentic
style and this or that is in fashion.
And I thought this is really cool.
This is like a Europeanization of male taste and culture.
But it was also very masculine.
It wasn't sort of like late seventies disco culture or early nineties rave
culture or,
or burning man culture.
You sort of more old school masculinity school.
Like,
I want to go to a proper barber and get proper haircut and like it's all flannel
and boots and whatever and I love that stuff.
Um,
but I think it kind of had its moment
and evaporated on.
I just have these,
they just priced themselves out of the market in Brooklyn,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Or they just got all too busy on Twitter.
Well that it always comes back to that.
Let's talk a little bit about mate selection.
Regardless of your sexuality,
there seems to be this new thing right now where if you're not open to dating
absolutely anyone under any circumstances,
no matter how they look or how they take care of themselves or whether they
brush their teeth or whether they have a penis or a vagina or any combination of
anything that if you are just to anything,
there is a pretty loud and growing boys out there that is trying to frame
everyone as a,
as a painter,
which is the reverse of what choosing a mate really has been about.
It's insane.
I mean,
for 509 I got ya.
I got emotional Miller or
500 million years,
right?
Our vertebrate ancestors had been choosing them mates selectively because that
is the highest stakes decision any organism makes is who do I recombine my jeans
with?
Right?
And so all the way through the coordinates and the vertebrates in the mammals
and the primates,
you get,
particularly females being choosy about,
you know,
who they breed with,
who sires are kids.
But then as soon as humans start doing pair bonds million 2 million years ago
and the male start investing more in offspring,
start forming longer term relationships,
then we also have incentives to be choosy about our female mates.
And so this is the one domain where if you have even a shred of libertarian in
you or you respect freedom of association at all,
or you think it's okay to care who you spend your life with and like what kind
of children you,
you create,
then mate choice should be it kind of domain of freedom,
right?
Like this is a good place to be prejudice,
so to speak,
right?
Yeah.
You should add some.
Uh,
should you just be discriminating,
have judgment.
Um,
and you can always be open to the idea that may be the current set of criteria
that I have.
Maybe could be nudged or improved or tweaked or maybe I'm subject to certain
stereotypes and maybe overcome those.
True,
of course people tend to get better at mate choice in their thirties and in
their teens.
But for someone to start lecturing you politically,
like you shouldn't be attracted to women.
You should be attracted to anybody or any,
any kind of being or what any species and the age like,
no,
let please let me be attracted to,
I'm attracted to because that should be like the pinnacle of human freedom.
Yeah.
If you don't believe in freedom anywhere else,
you should believe in May choice,
freedom.
It should be a fundamental human right,
I think.
And where you get horrible totalitarian societies really infringing on mate
choice freedom.
Like you're not allowed to marry that person or you know,
you have to do an arranged marriage to that person.
We kind of recoil at that and go,
that's horrible.
And yet in America we have busy bodies,
virtue signalers um,
telling us your matrix criteria are too narrow.
So where do gay people fit in all of this?
Then I add a biological or an evolutionary perspective.
You've brought up the point of passing on genes many times down gay couples or
gay people,
whether you're a couple or not.
Don't do that.
At least biologically speaking.
Yup.
Um,
so what,
what do you make of that condition?
Is that even the right word?
And I'm going to get,
I'm going to get us both in trouble.
Probably just for me asking the question.
It's called a trait trait traits.
Pretty neutral.
Okay.
Alright.
Trey,
it's pretty neutral.
Well,
here's the fascinating thing about homosexuality is people have been developing
or trying to develop series of male homosexuality and it's kind of evolutionary
origins and functions for 30,
40 years and there is no good theory of it yet.
It's a complete mystery.
I've never seen any compelling explanation of male homosexuality.
So,
so what would be a compelling,
compelling argument would be,
okay,
there's costs of being like exclusively attracted to your own sex and therefore
not typically having as many kids,
but there's some countervailing benefits of some sort,
maybe benefits to your extended family or benefits to your group or something
else.
But nobody can make the math work enough to,
to kind of explain that.
Um,
female bisexuality is much easier,
right?
You can go,
well as long as a woman is sometimes attracted to men enough to have kids,
then also being attracted to women might be no cost at all.
Or it might even be a benefit in terms of social networking,
making friends sex as a great way to make friends.
Um,
if a lot more males were bisexual,
that would be equally easy to explain.
Um,
it's exclusive homosexuality,
that's very hard to explain.
It certainly exists.
It exists at a,
you know,
a percentage that's much,
much higher than you can explain is just,
well,
it's just mutations where it's just maladaptive.
That won't work.
So this is where I'll be kind of epistemically humble and say,
hey man,
I have no idea.
It's an,
it's a fascinating problem.
Maybe somebody will crack it within 10 or 20.
Right.
It's interesting because if you were coming at it from another perspective,
like a religious perspective,
let's say you would find that to be a moral quandary that then you could
extrapolate all sorts of different judgements on.
Yeah.
But I can see the way you answered it's like just is a thing.
Maybe we'll get more data on it,
but it is.
But what do you make of the fact that there are seemingly many more bisexual
women where,
I don't know any gay couple that one of the guys is thinking out at night to
bang a woman.
I've never heard of that.
But you have heard of obviously straightened couples where the guy is,
you know,
on the DL or whatever.
Yeah.
Well my girlfriend Diana Fleishman has a whole theory of female bisexuality.
That's,
that's to do with the social networking benefits.
Um,
but then the question is,
yeah,
why don't the men do that too?
Cause like if,
if you're a guy and you kind of swing both ways,
then like doing gay sex can be a great way to make male friends also.
And it's,
well now I know
we have our,
uh,
our promo for the show.
And so in a way the quandary isn't,
why do any male homosexuals exist?
The quandary is why aren't all males and females bisexual?
And do you think some of that years from now we might look back and go,
Whoa,
that's just societal pressure.
It might be.
I think certainly there's a huge amount of stigma against male bisexuals from
both sexist.
Um,
but especially women.
female bisexuality used to be stigmatized maybe 30 years ago and not so much
anymore.
Yeah.
So it could change.
What are some of the other topics that are,
that are really on your mind these days?
Let's hit up effective altruism.
Yeah,
let's talk about that.
Um,
I don't know if you've had many guests on talking about the fact of altruism,
but it's not a ton,
actually.
It's sort of my hot topic of the last few years.
So it's a social movement,
a moral movement in some of the smartest young people I've ever met.
And their basic goal in life is do the most good.
They can based on reason and evidence rather than sentimentality and virtue
signaling.
I've done a little bit of this sort of in an ancillary way with some of the
libertarians that I yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And so the kind of major domains they tend to focus on are things like how do we
get charities to be more effective at reducing global poverty or promoting
global public health?
How do we overcome factory farming and be nice to animals and promote animal
welfare?
And so a lot of the effect of altruists are Vegan for ethical reasons and then a
lot of them are focused on just survival of the species.
How do we reduce existential risks to humanity like nuclear war,
bio weapons,
um,
and artificial intelligence risks.
So maybe the most distinctive thing they have is this kind of ultra longterm
perspective that's like,
we are just these transient little beings.
The thing that really matters is what is humanity turn into?
How long did we last?
Do we colonize the universe or do we fail?
And folks who think most seriously about that think it's actually that lasting,
minimizing existential risk that is absolutely crucial and everything else is
just kind of fluff and bullshit.
The transhumanist through would sort of fit within.
Is there a risk?
So I love this stuff because I'm a PSI Phi guy.
Everything I mentioned Philip k Dick before.
I mean every one of his stories or books are about the inevitability of all of
these things.
Is there a risk though?
We'll always looking at what's beyond the horizon instead of going on right now?
I don't really think there's a risk unless like the vast majority of humans
became effective altruists there's already so many people who are obsessed with
um,
you know,
diversity and equity and inclusion and economic growth and all the ordinary
problems that politicians talk about that that's covered this already.
A lot of smart people working on that.
The big neglected topics tend to be the kind of science fictiony topics where
you need a sort of cadre of genius.
Ask Bs,
right to work on it when nobody else is taking it seriously.
Yeah.
Well speaking of the ass,
because that's the,
that's an interesting one.
If we wanted to get into on this a little,
a little controversial as well.
Um,
what,
what is that all about?
That so many of the creators now or the people that are coming out of the tech
world,
even though you can obviously make plenty of arguments that the 10 world is now
in its sort of implosion and certainly not the creative place it was say 10
years ago,
but there's so much creativity came out of a world that had so many people that
were seemingly uncreated.
[inaudible]
I think it's fascinating.
Um,
I sort of identifies moderately ask,
be myself kind of high functioning Asperger's and I've written some stuff about
how um,
neurodiversity issues like being asked to kind of rub up against free speech
issues cause like can you explain that people who are asked,
we don't always do a good job of understanding the beliefs and desires of other
people and particularly what they might find offensive.
Right?
So they might just say something,
so I might just say shit.
And then these really surprised that it was distressing to someone.
And so if you have a model of speech that says you must never cause a fence,
that assumes you can anticipate what will cause a fence.
And a lot of people can't anticipate that because their brains don't work that
way.
So you either need to say,
okay,
as bs,
you can never say anything
or cut them some slack and say,
we understand you'll offend people once in awhile,
but that's okay because that's just,
that's part of your deal,
man.
I've never thought about this,
but does this somehow explain what's going on in Silicon Valley right now you
have a bunch of people who are somewhat socially awkward,
let's say,
created incredible technology that allowed us to all connect,
but then when voices that are exposed,
I suppose that's a horrible way framing it within voices that are a little out
there or a little contrary or whatever that might include us actually get out
there.
The only way they can deal with it is to shut that voice off or something like
that.
Like,
which is why we're seeing so much d platforming and silencing and they're right.
They have to be overly systematizing about it,
that they have to be like,
oh man,
I can't,
I can't navigate these gray areas if I'm running a social media platform or
Patrion or whatever.
Right.
So I'm gonna just have a hard and fast rule that says if I get enough
complaints,
I d platform that person,
or um,
I don't know the difference between porn and erotica and just slightly sexy art.
So I'm going to say no nipples or whatever.
That's a kind of asked be response to getting blow back
from people were like,
you don't really know why they're upset.
So in a weird way,
if you have a bunch of the creators of Silicon Valley then are coming from that
world,
and then you subtly bring in a bunch of executives that come from the social
justice world that really shows like a,
uh,
that's a match made in hell.
Right?
It's just matter.
Anti matter.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's terrible.
And
okay,
what I hoped would happen is that maybe five or 10 years ago,
it seemed like,
Whoa,
like tech is dominating culture generally on tech is dominated by aspy.
So hopefully ask me values of being kind of tolerant and eccentric and nerdy and
like getting weird little enthusiasms that that would kind of trickle down and
create a more tolerant culture.
Is that what you would have predicted,
say 10 years ago?
Yeah.
Really.
And instead you have the opposite.
You have the,
the social justice activists taking over and basically saying
all of that quirky freedom that you,
you asked me people value,
we're going to legislate that away.
You can't have that.
Um,
and it's,
it's tragic.
I hope the pendulum swing swings back,
but um,
as long as the leaders of the social media platforms don't have the guts to say,
look,
this is our people.
Um,
outspoken,
eccentric,
slightly socially oblivious people,
and that's,
and the rest of you just have to kind of suck it up and deal with it.
That's what they should
be doing.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
I'm at the point with all this and you know how Facebook,
Youtube and Twitter and patriotic and the whole thing,
I'm really at the point of this where I actually believe that that solution is
gone.
I don't think it can come from the top anymore.
I really don't believe that.
I think that thing has become so corroded that I would say the only way it can
come is now from the bottom and then the people will basically rise up against
these things and I know that like it's sort of pie in the sky because what does
that even mean?
Do we all sign off on the same day?
Do we all be,
you know,
whatever that means.
But I almost see that as the only way to do this because they've had,
we've done everything else or,
or the government will get involved in.
That certainly rings all the bells that I'm not happy with on my libertarian
side.
Yeah.
I,
I think,
at least in terms of universities,
the only solution to,
to some of the university problems is the government actually saying at least to
the public universities that are in principle bound by the constitution.
You guys have to obey the first amendment or you lose federal funding.
I think that's the only leverage.
Yeah.
And I was really kind of hoping that POTUS would do that at some point in the
last year or two and pretty disappointed that he hasn't,
well,
in a weird way he almost benefits the more that they go against it.
Right?
Yeah.
Because that feeds his base of aggrieved and politically correct.
You know,
that they see political correctness running muck.
Yeah.
Something like that.
Um,
all right.
Before we finish up gimme gimme one thing where at the beginning of 2019 right
now,
give me one thing that we should be sort of thinking about that we're not
thinking about right now.
I love the thought experiment of like,
once Elon Musk succeeds and we start colonizing Mars,
what,
what are the relationships and social structures in the Mars colony is going to
look like?
I'm fascinated by this,
this issue,
like are the colony is going to be like
communist utopia?
Is are they going to be libertarian,
um,
aspirational states?
Are they,
is everyone going to do monogamous lifelong marriage?
Is it going to be crazy polyamorous,
kinky stuff?
I think it's great to think about this stuff before we attempt it.
And I think Mars is going to be this amazing experiment or like this colony gets
formed,
paste on these social and sexual assumptions and this one gets formed and this
one fails catastrophically or,
or it like,
it doesn't work well enough in it that just borrows the organization of this
other place.
So I think it'll be this incredible kind of behavioral Science Laboratory.
And I can't,
where I say that's not too far from the way the America we set up right.
That this exactly.
To be those places of experiment.
Yeah.
Um,
it's,
yeah,
it's the way the east coast was 200,
250 years ago.
And I think,
um,
the difference now is the colonies will be able to communicate with each other
and with us and be able to measure a bunch of outcomes and deliberately
experiment.
And I think we need to kind of get out ahead of that and start like rereading
all of our classic science fiction and figuring out how is this going to apply
for reals now,
now that we do it.
Yeah.
Which is still related to why you think guard is important because fiction's
just as important.
I mean,
you realize you've all lands that eventually they figure it out.
They have their tea party and then we blow them up like,
yeah.
But they do beautiful art nouveau like domes in the meanwhile.
Yeah.
Jeffrey,
I'm so glad we finally did this it again for sure.
And if you want to see a good combination of bright,
smart thought and snark on Twitter,
follow Jeffrey at primal Polly.